swiss banking has always been the center
of attention for hollywood
when it comes to sketchy activities
whether we're dealing with tax evasion
or securities fraud
hollywood suggests that swiss banks are
the go-to safe haven
while there is some truth to this notion
this is not the primary reason that most
individuals choose to go with swiss
banks
in fact the real reason that likely
applies to you as well
so here's why the rich really prefers
with banking and why you need a swiss
bank gown today
more than ever starting off
let's take a look at how switzerland
even became famous for banking
the strong reputation of swiss banks
isn't a new development by any means
it actually stretches way back to the
16th century
at the time europe was undergoing a
massive spiritual transformation
the scientific findings of famous
scientists such as leonardo da vinci and
galileo raised skepticism
surrounding the existence of god we also
had revolutionaries like martin luther
who challenged the control
and teachings of the roman catholic
church this search of questioning
long-lasting ideals
eventually erupted and led to the famous
protestant reformation
some rulers supported the reformation as
this meant they could take away power
from the church
while others stood strong in the support
for the church the religious freedom in
your country however
could change out a whim if the king
passed away it didn't take long for the
son or daughter to take over
and potentially switch to the other side
one of the only places however that was
consistently neutral on the subject was
reformed areas of switzerland
including geneva basil and zurich this
neutrality
attracted a large number of huguenots
and protestant refugees from all over
europe
geographically speaking switzerland is
literally in the center of present-day
france
germany and italy so switzerland was the
closest refugee for much of europe
meanwhile from switzerland's perspective
they didn't actually have much going for
them
they were small landlocked and had
little natural resources
so when they saw an influx of talented
refugees flooding into the area
they leaned into the opportunity they
stood strong in terms of consistent
religious neutrality
and this persuaded many wealthy
businessmen to store their money in
switzerland throughout the 1600s
switzerland continued to build up their
reputation as a safe haven
but during this time period the trust in
switzerland was just that
trust in 1713 however switzerland
decided to up their commitment
the council of geneva would pass
legislation that prohibited swiss banks
from disclosing client information
originally this was simply designed to
provide depositors with more security
and privacy avoiding taxes wasn't that
big of a concern
at the time in most countries income
taxes
weren't even a thing so the primary
reason a wealthy europeans used swiss
banks was truly for security
near the end of the 1700s we saw the
american and french revolutions
a plethora of political disputes and
dozens of wars across
europe so during these uncertain times
storing your money in a neutral place
was extremely important
moving on to the 1800s this is when
countries around the world really
started to levy income taxes
the us for instance implemented their
first income tax of three percent on
august 5th
1861. though income taxes started out
and just a couple of percent per year
it didn't take long for them to grow
into the double digits and
by the end of the 1800s people were
looking for clever ways to avoid paying
income taxes to the government
given the privacy neutrality and
security of swiss banks
they became the first target for tax
evasion schemes for the first couple of
decades
neighboring countries didn't do much
about individuals leveraging swiss bank
accounts for tax evasion
you see income taxes were a new topic at
the time
and the governments around the world
didn't want to approach a topic too
aggressively
so they gave swiss banks quite a bit of
slack however
as income taxes became more accepted by
society government started to crack down
on swiss banks in 1932 for instance
french authorities raided swiss banks in
paris and this revealed mass amounts of
untaxed money but this did not make
things better
this was during the great depression and
switzerland was already seeing large
amounts of capital leaving their banks
and they weren't going to let these
countries come in and take even more
so in 1934 switzerland passed the swiss
banking act of
1934 which made it a crime to disclose a
client's banking information to a third
party without the client's consent
and this gave rise to switzerland
becoming the tax haven
of the world throughout the rest of the
1900s wealthy individuals around the
world
sent their money to switzerland in order
to avoid taxes and or launder their
money
but since the 1980s countries have
heavily clamped down on tax evasion
especially with the help of technology
nowadays
every single transaction is logged and
easily traceable by the authorities
so it's extremely difficult to even get
your money to switzerland without the
authorities catching on
but even if you somehow got your money
there now you have to deal with opening
an account
while it's true that switzerland doesn't
really care about whether or not you pay
taxes in your home country
they do care about how you made the
money swiss banks require extensive
documentation regarding the sources of
your money
and they do not put up with criminal
activities in fact
even if you slide by the swiss banker
screening your swiss banking rights
won't hold up
if a prosecutor brings up significant
evidence suggesting that your money was
made through illegal sources
such as drug trafficking organized crime
and securities fraud
so money laundering through swiss banks
is quite difficult
and in most cases you will be caught
just like the wolf of wall street
if you made your money through legal
sources however then you may very well
be able to use swiss bank accounts to
evade taxes
but in 99 of cases multi-millionaires
and billionaires who made their money
through legal avenues
have no interest in straight-up evading
taxes sure
they'll use every single loophole they
can find in the book but
committing straight up tax evasion is
where they draw the line as you know
they don't want to go to jail moreover
there's no point in even having all that
untaxed money
in switzerland let's say you get past
all the safeguards in place and
successfully move your untaxed money to
a swiss bank
how are you even going to spend it are
you going to move to switzerland
are you going to eventually transfer
back to your home country
whatever you do every transaction you
make is just going to increase the
likelihood of getting caught
so in reality vast majority of money
stored in swiss banks
is not subject to tax evasion or money
laundering
something else to consider is that there
are plenty of places where it's way
easier to commit these activities such
as the cayman islands
but then why did the rich love swiss
banks well
there's three primary reasons for this
love starting with neutrality
just like in the 16th century
switzerland is still a completely
neutral country
they don't participate in wars they
don't have any allies
they're not part of the european union
and they maintain positive diplomatic
relations with nearly every single
country
in the world many countries have fallen
in switzerland's footsteps
like finland ireland and sweden but
switzerland's neutrality is by far the
oldest and the most respected
now this isn't that big of a deal for
the us and most western countries
but for brought to individuals and
countries with the device of politics
it makes sense to store your money in a
neutral country think about millionaires
and billionaires in countries like saudi
arabia
iraq afghanistan china and russia
jack ma and joseph said for instance may
have major ties with swiss banks
we know that sai's private jet is
mortgaged by credit suisse
so who knows how much money this mega
billionaire stores in switzerland
as you can see switzerland's neutrality
is extremely attractive for many
billionaires around the world
but this is not that big of a deal for
most western billionaires
what is a major deal for western
billionaires however is inflation
and with all of the money printing from
the federal reserve and the european
central bank
inflation is a bigger threat than ever
before
now the federal reserve assures us that
inflation is temporary
and that will average 2-3 inflation like
always
but even a single year of increased
inflation could be quite costly for rich
individuals
let's say inflation runs at four percent
instead of three percent for just
one year if you have one billion dollars
in cash
you just burned an extra 10 million
dollars worth of purchasing power for no
reason
by putting the one billion dollars into
a swiss bank account however
you can not only avoid the extra
percentage of inflation but you can
often avoid inflation
altogether you see switzerland takes the
value of their currency and their
monetary policy
extremely seriously given that banking
is their crown jewel
they refuse to print trillions of
dollars to fund eye-popping government
budgets
and they'll basically do anything
including negative interest rates and
reducing the money supply
to maintain near-zero inflation rates
this is in stark contrast to any other
western country
and is extremely evident in their
historical currency exchange rate
if we take a look at the usd this was
frank conversion rate
we'll see that in the year 2000 a single
dollar would give you 1.7 swiss francs
today a single dollar will only give you
0.9 swiss francs
in other words the us dollar nearly
halved in comparison to this was frank
if we look at a longer timeframe this
disparity just becomes even larger
in 1975 a single british pound was
equivalent to approximately
six swiss francs today a british pound
is only equivalent to 1.27 swiss francs
this means that the british pound has
nearly dropped 5x in value compared to
the swiss franc
to put that into perspective even if we
measure from the bottom of the 1974
stock market crash
you would have only grown your money 12x
by perfectly timing the market
with that being said if you're gonna
hold large amounts of cash for a long
period of time
it's a no-brainer to hold it in swiss
francs and that brings me on to the
final reason that the rich
love swiss banks and that's unparalleled
peace of mind
switzerland has one of the strictest
reserve requirements and lending
requirements in the world
in fact switzerland is so confident in
their system that all swiss banks are
insured
100 in the u.s fdic insurance only
stretches up to 250 thousand dollars
now will swiss banks actually be able to
pay out the promise 100
if things go bad i'm not sure but what i
am sure about
is that they will pay out way more than
any bank in any other country
in that same situation and that's why
6.5 trillion dollars
or 25 of all global cross-border assets
are stored in swiss banks
today have you guys ever considered
opening a swiss bank account
comment that down below also drop a like
if you think other countries should take
better care of their currencies like
switzerland
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one